más de mil muertes registradas este
martes la alza repentina del número de
muertos por kobe 19 en rusia preocupa al
gobierno en moscú anunciaron un nuevo
confinamiento de cuatro meses para los
mayores de 60 años que no han recibido
una vacuna y recomendaron que un tercio
de los empleados deben quedarse en casa
por su lado la ministra de salud propuso
una semana de licencia para todos los
rusos con el objetivo de limitar la
circulación branch y proponemos al
presidente de la federación rusa
proclamar no laborable la semana del 30
de octubre al 7 de noviembre en todo el
territorio pero a la espera de la
respuesta de vladimir putin el país se
enfrenta a una campaña de vacunación
estancada actualmente sólo el 35 por
ciento de la población está
completamente vacunada y según una
encuesta reciente más de la mitad de los
rusos no quieren recibir el biológico
teniendo como ciudadano todo el mundo
tiene una responsabilidad social al
menos hacerse una prueba y respetar las
medidas de distanciamiento aunque muchos
las ponen en cuestión les animo a que
todo el mundo se vacune a que use
tapabocas los guantes y a respetar el
distanciamiento social y sobre todo
hacer funcionar su sentido
muchas regiones ya habían introducido el
pase sanitario para entrar a lugares
públicos el lunes la ciudad de san
petesburgo anunció su extensión a
lugares culturales y deportivos desde el
primero de noviembre rusia sigue siendo
el país europeo más tocado por la
pandemia con un recuento oficial de al
menos 225 mil 300 muertos debido al
hobbit 19 aunque muchos coinciden en que
la cifra podría ser mayor